no no no no
no
no
start serving the Blues
ah
okey dokey
suppose it's time to get this show on
the road
can't hear me
one second let us sort that you should
you should be hearing me
Okay so
all right Stephen it might be an issue
on your end then because everyone else
says that they can
so
um all right
oh sorry for some reason I thought you
said you you okay so you can seen it my
brain turned that into a negative
out of nowhere I don't know why
welcome and yes cheers to you as well
Gozer
thank you Meg
I haven't worn this in uh in quite a
while
so thought that was nice to bust out I
also just barely shot a tick tock in it
so there's there's that too
uh getting drunk no no I am not
I will be uh enjoying my time with you
folks but I'm not getting drunk
um and just for the record it's not just
a top it's a full dress
which makes it slightly more acceptable
that I'm not wearing pants than is
normally the case
um not that I don't wear pants when I
shoot or stream of course I do
oh
hope everybody is doing well
I got great news I finally got my PS5
after three years of waiting and a new
cat named chesh Cheshire chest for short
oh that's great Logan I'm really happy
for you
um spending the night in London just saw
the woman in black play it's excellent
I'd really like to see that that play
like I know the movie and I like the
movie a lot
but um
I'd be curious to see how the how the
play is
any plans for the New Year oh yeah
Lots
like I have
I have things it's not like complete
everything I'm gonna do but like I have
things on my docket planned out into
August
hmm yes I have plenty of plans
uh oh hey Phillip Hawkins good to see
you I see you stopping in
um Americans are getting dhmis ah
Evelyn's I
acronyms and abbreviations are really
bad my brain doesn't catch most of them
unless I'm like already super familiar
with them so I don't know what that is
I'm sorry to make you type stuff all the
way out but
I I don't know what that is
I look like I could be a cat person I'm
liking the ears
my sister got me a DC themed cookbook
I'm not kidding
that sounds
terrifying also potentially fascinating
would I be interested in playing sonic
Frontiers no
absolutely not and that's nothing
against Sonic I don't have any
particular
uh Nostalgia for Sonic the
um the thing is like fully rendered 3D
like free roaming camera games they make
me motion sick and I think something
especially with the speed of Sonic I
would get motion sick very quickly so no
that is a hard no don't hug me I'm
scared ah I knew I knew it was gonna be
something I recognized once you told me
um I never really watched the
um the YouTube shorts of it it just it's
it seems like one of those things that
like I totally get why people are very
into it it doesn't the little bits I've
seen don't really seem like my cup of
tea so
uh am I gonna watch the ball drop most
likely yep
a geeky cookbook could be fun make a
themed dinner party yeah potentially
I can make Batman cupcakes so
is there anything in particular that
makes them Batman
other than like the design
are you meant to include like the kind
of
um non-parels that look like pearls so
you like have the busted pearl necklace
on them
sorry that's kind of awful
[Music]
blue dress blue glasses decked out in
Blue tonight I know right I match and
everything it's great
August we have we need to have a
schedule filling conversation we do uh
carowind absolutely and like I don't
mean like I have every week planned out
into August because I don't but there
are some things that like I like if I do
that that would be the big thing for
that month so I've like paced those out
but like a lot of these could be moved
it it's a rough sketch we'll go over it
um
that's fair it's pretty specific style
wise yeah I I really have had to
completely abandon fully 3D games like I
might I might get back into them
so like what was it I think it was
tinykin I saw some gameplay footage for
and that didn't seem to bother me too
much I think it's because of the
character sprite
is 2D and stays turned at the same angle
to the camera so like I might might be
able to do that one the issue for me is
it's not while speed compounds it that's
not even the only Factor because I I got
motion sick playing The Stanley Parable
which isn't even like a fast the camera
whips around kind of thing
and um I still got motion sick
my partner got me copies for the scripts
for Smith and Jones the one who fell to
Earth and His Dark Materials signed by
various cast and crew oh wow guard
that's great that's really thoughtful
hope that I enjoyed my Christmas I did
enjoy my Christmas it was quite nice it
was
it's a family event so
excuse me it was lovely
uh
our Batman cupcakes just cupcakes that
Alfred makes but Batman takes Public
Credit for
love it love it Meg
uh what are my thoughts on Old Comics uh
from the late 90s early 2000s like no
man's land Nightwing Officer Down okay
you seem to be zooming in on Batman
specifically I haven't read a ton of
them I did like no man's land I thought
that was pretty good
um but like I I had kind of fallen off
Comics by the late 90s I was reading
them regularly in the early mid 90s uh
by late 90s I'd fallen off them so
um
I haven't read a ton of stuff from that
era
see our philosophy is thank you so very
much for the Super Chat uh reminder
Super Chat uh while I do try and keep up
with the chat uh otherwise I do not
guarantee that I will read a comment if
it is not as part of a super chat but
the Super Chat also gets you a heart of
appreciation from me to you
hiya
um
by don't talk about the Timeless child
do you mean avoid the subject entirely
or could it actually be contradicted if
relevant in future I.E the doctor calls
Hartnell his first life again
um
so all right
I have said that my personal preference
um for how to deal with the Timeless
child in Doctor Who is to ignore it to
basically treat it uh exactly the same
way that the show treated the doctors
half-human idea that came from the TV
movie just don't bring it up again don't
deal with it leave it alone
um
now in regards to what you're
specifically talking about the thing is
like
I can't think of too many instances
where it's actually
super plot relevant
to specifically label something like
Cardinal as the first life I think the
only time I can think of work or at
least the most recent time that that was
super relevant was twice Upon a Time
and even then like you could bring it up
and it's not it's theoretically not a
complete
um
uh contradiction because to the Doctor's
memory it was their first life even if
the doctor now understands that there
were more lives prior to that
um the fact is they don't remember them
so I think it's fair to still call that
the first life but again I don't think
there are very many story instances
where you actually have to number it you
can just reference like in another life
in an older life in an earlier life I
don't think you have to go out of your
way to number it most of the time and
the only reason it was important in
um twice Upon a Time was because you
know contrasting this uh reservation uh
to Regeneration with the very first time
that the doctor went through that was
actually relevant again first time that
you remembered is the situation we're
now in but like I again
I don't think that there's necessarily a
problem or that it even is a flat out
contradiction to continue for the doctor
even to continue to call Hartnell
um their first life because it is still
their first remembered life
Supreme
Omega thank you very much for the Super
Chat thoughts on Doctor Who Christmas
specials
I so
I know in the past
that
um
I have said I don't really like the
Christmas specials all that much the
thing is I've kind of softened on that
not to say I like them better but I
don't think I hold them to the same
standard as the rest of the show which
is what I used to do and it that was the
primary basis on which I would say I
don't really like them all that much
and I while I do think it is a little
bit of an excuse
to
just offer a reason of why you're gonna
grade something on a curve
sometimes you just do it anyways
and you know it part of me still goes
like well you just you're just allowing
something to have a lower excuse me a
lower standard because oh it's the
Christmas specials they're different but
I mean they are
they are so yeah I'm I'm
while they are rarely rarely
particularly high ranking
um episodes for me they are still
enjoyable and I feel Kinder towards them
than I have historically
um
let's see what's my most touching
Christmas present ever this year the
emotional counselor I go to gave me a
culture themed mug which I told
because I've told her what it means to
me so many times oh that's really nice
um unfortunately with
with the way my brain tends to work
um
I'm that I'm really bad at answering
that because I
I know what things are presents or like
that I own that were presents and I can
usually remember who from
um but remembering whether it was
birthday whether it was Christmas uh it
all gets muddled
I and most touching is
is difficult to parse
um I will say the one that like was
probably the quintessential uh Christmas
gift for me the one that like when I
think about what Christmas felt like
immediately comes to my head was when I
was I would have been
seven I think
and
I got for Christmas not only a Nintendo
Entertainment System
but
um
now it wasn't even seven I was
sick no I was seven uh I got a Nintendo
Entertainment System a bunch of games
for it and a subscription to Nintendo
Power which I had for years and years
and years and I've still got those
issues packed up in the attic somewhere
all that stuff together like that's that
is what I tend to think of when I think
of Christmas
anything I'm looking forward to in 2023
yeah knows a handful of things the main
thing that jumps to mind is
um
well there's the Doctor Who specials
obviously but there's also
um
across the spiderverse
I don't I'm not going to do a most
anticipated of 2023 list this year I
have historically done those I'm not
doing it for two reasons
the first is
um they were never particularly
I can talk particularly
um well-viewed videos and the other
thing is
between the fact that stuff keeps moving
like across the spiderverse was on my
list for this year but it got bumped so
stuff keeps moving and on top of that
there's going to be a bunch of stuff
that I don't even know is coming out and
like it's it's a list that really only
works for
the kinds of movies that get announced
years in advance and that's like Marvel
DC uh Star Wars and that kind of thing
and honestly
um I'm not super looking forward to the
films in those franchises right now
anyways like I'm still looking forward
to them but not enough oh let's count
down how excited I am kind of way so it
it does it's not an idea that I have as
much enthusiasm for
and um
excuse me and in addition to that like
like I said just
at a base level those videos never never
got that many views
favorite Christmas food
um
nostalgically for me
um because my grandmother would make
these every year it is popcorn balls
which are just it's just
popped popcorn
pressed together with molasses into a
ball that you just eat
yeah I have a lot of nostalgia wrapped
up in that
oh
sorry
part of the raspberry got lost
do you think Daredevil will work now
that the new series has been reported to
be kid oriented orientated I haven't
been following the production
I suspect kid orientated is probably an
overstatement I think it's probably much
more likely to be you know PG-13 like
most of the Marvel stuff is as opposed
to the distinctly r that the Netflix
version was
I think it'll I think Daredevil is a
character will adapt just fine
um because the thing is while I don't
think there was anything wrong with it
going that way Daredevil definitely of
the Netflix characters
was the one who probably needed the
extra level of violence the least
um
well maybe Iron Fist but those those two
didn't really need it Luke Cage because
it was because of the nature of not just
depicting that part of New York but
talking about the violence of the black
experience specifically kind of needed a
bit more and Jessica Jones given that
the
um very heightened
um emotional and traumatic
um it's actual violence that goes on in
that yeah that needed to be marked for
older audiences but Daredevil you could
adapt down relatively easily you just
you just have it you just have his
punch-ups result in more bruises and
less blood I don't honestly think it's
going to be that big of a shift now
whether or not they ever try and bring
the Punisher over that one might be a
problem
because even if you don't do it super
bloody his whole deal is that he kills
people that's his that's his entire log
line
favorite Doctor Who Christmas special
depending on when you ask me my answer
probably changes I think it's probably
husbands of River Song
but like I said my answer will change
depending on when you ask me
tried to watch Spirited on Apple TV
multiple times I love Christmas stuff
and Ryan and will but I can't stomach it
oof I I saw I saw it not even Complete
Trailers I saw bits of trailers and I
was like I pass that's pass have I ever
had a secret santa yeah usually at uh
at work related things
um did you go to Gallifrey one
Jody's so lovely it comes I hope you get
to meet her one day I did go
this 2022 I did go
um she
uh was not present for that one I
believe she's gonna be at the one coming
which I'm not going to because I can't
afford it um for the upcoming one
um but I've been to Gallifrey one twice
and it's been lovely
do you feel Doctor Who should use the
concept of time travel more conceptually
big Finnish uses cerebral idea of
paradoxes and rewriting time and erasing
events and people more explicitly
um
I would say
a little more than it currently does but
I also don't want that to become the
standard of what Doctor Who on TV is
but like they could stand to do it a
little more than they do
provided they have inventive things to
do with it because that there are still
patterns and ruts you can get caught
into
with the DC situation and such floss
flux it's impossible to predict what's
coming yeah there's
there's that too
see oh hey Angus thank you very much for
the super chat if you re-ranked the
Christmas holiday specials would you
include spyfall part one as it is of
course the first episode of series 12
just going out on New Year's Day I would
not it is episode because like even
though that release
on New Year's Day it wasn't a special it
was the start of the series
so no I would not include that because
regardless of when it aired it wasn't a
special it was just the premiere episode
so if I ever do a have I done a ranking
of the Christmas specials I must have at
some point if I ever do a re-rank
um maybe maybe for next Christmas
um no that would not be included
popcorn bottles sound delish I'd rather
like them
um are you planning to ever redo your
top 10 worst episode list for modern
Doctor Who uh eventually
yeah eventually I will
I think
I want to get a little bit more distance
from the um
from the chimney Whitaker era
because I know there's some episodes who
are gonna that are gonna end up on it I
just don't want
I don't want it to be biased against
those so like I need that distance a
little bit
um let's see
do you still identify with your male
name uh I've forgotten what it is but
just curious
um
yeah
I don't I like I use Vera in a lot more
places now just because at a certain
point it becomes easier
um so and it's Nathaniel for the record
which I'll say because it's not a dead
name
it's just it's another name
um But as time has gone on and I've
allowed
well I as I've as my more Femme
presenting self has become the standard
me just sort of having Vera
be uh the more unified name that I use
across platforms it just kind of felt
just felt like the easier and more
natural thing to do
there like wasn't any plan and like and
then I will fully phase out in a thing
of like
that's not on my to-do list
or anything
uh have I ever seen d23 nope have zero
interest
got a jet seasons greetings okay Meg it
was good to see you thank you for
stopping in
Will Ferrell's a little bit Hit or Miss
for me Will Ferrell is a little bit miss
or miss or miss or oh that kind of hit
for me so
hmm
one of my top five anime
um generally when people say anime they
mean anime shows I don't even think
no I guess I have seen five all the way
through I'm not sure if I'd have what
I'd call a top five
um
I can give you a top three
uh which would be vision of escaflowne
uh Ghost in the Shell Standalone complex
and Cowboy Bebop be my top three
I haven't seen that many others from
start to finish and the ones that I have
I didn't like enough that I would want
to put them in a top
thing so that's what I'm gonna go with
uh does that mean that the Snowman is
just a special or is a special or just
episode six of series seven no the
Snowman is a special because Series 7
was broken up into two halves with the
Christmas special the snowmen Landing in
the middle so yes that one still counts
I really like your hair style by the way
does it have a name I want to get mine
um cut similar for my birthday I mean I
all that it is is that I I just have
um I just have an undercut all the way
around
that's I I don't know if the if the
um
style as a whole has a name but like
that's all it is is I've just got all
this it's all an undercut and like my
hair falling the way it is my part being
there that's just naturally where my
hair wants to be parted anyways so that
that just works
oh let's see I loved how you impressive
meat water on your Twitch stream yeah
I'm sure you did okay I actually didn't
forget but I'm worried explaining why I
was uh
cons hold on but I'm worried explaining
why I was convinced I would maybe count
as dead naming
Natalie Nguyen I'm not sure I totally
follow your question there 255 A.D your
wording is throwing me off there
so I can't I can't quite follow the the
inquiry
every time I hear Nathaniel I think of a
song for the musical version of War of
the Worlds
it is the funny thing is
um
the funny thing for me is that
I I'm
I'm not used to hearing Nathaniel
um in fiction or entertainment because
most people in real life and
um
and in fiction don't go by the whole
thing they go by a shortened version
Nate Nathan they don't use the whole
thing very often
so the the few times that it happens
um it they stand out to me like I did a
tick tock a little while back basically
calling out specifically uh Crazy
Ex-Girlfriend
because there is a character named
Nathaniel
and if you know the show then you know
the reason they call him Nathaniel
instead of anything shorter is because
yeah he's rich and spoiled and struck
and stuck up and it's considered kind of
the snooty
pompous way to do it is just to say the
whole name
that's a great character that's a great
show though
um I was convinced I was misremembering
your masculine name because it's oh it's
also her dead name and was convinced I
was conflating oh okay
I follow you now yeah no no worries
about that
um
Sony's rebooting Stuart Little
why why would you do that
Andy Stevenson goes by Nate now though I
think not exclusively for example the ND
is still in his Twitter bio
um yeah I'd seen that I'd seen that he's
he's he's been going through a journey
for a while and it's been nice just to
see him get his feet under himself over
time it's been really great
ah greetings from Brazil greetings to
you as well
um
hmm
[Music]
you are spooked by Daniel Radcliffe's
kid and the woman in black sharing your
name as I recall oh I forgot that that
was that kid's name
oh dang it
I had forgotten that thanks Gozer
in the 2000s DC DC thoughts on writers
turning Batman into a paranoid jerk who
creates secret plans to take down the
JLA and treating the bat family like
crap so
ah
I have very mixed feelings on that on
the one hand I do think that in a vacuum
Batman having a plan on how to take down
every member of the JLA basically just
in case they get mind controlled turn
evil they have to deal with some kind of
evil clone version whatever makes total
sense that is absolutely something
almost any version of Batman could and
should do
the um the level that it was taken to
and a lot of this
a lot of this was in the wake of
identity crisis
which is one more reason to hate
identity crisis and look given what
happened in identity crisis and what
Batman
um came to realize had happened
it gave him good justification for
upping his level of paranoia that didn't
make it any more interesting to watch
it's the classic issue of no my issue
isn't that this direction you've taken
the character isn't explained or
Justified it's that I don't like this
direction for the character it's not
about the reason that your The Narrative
reason that you have for doing it's that
I just don't like it so it kind of falls
into that whole mess and
um as far as treating the bat family
like crap I don't
I don't remember how much of the
specifics were going on at the time but
yeah I do remember them in general
really it was decided they wanted to
lean extra hard into loner Batman which
in the um in the movies you can get away
with because you can
um you know just set it up so there
isn't the bat family but in the comics
there is and there's that history so if
you're gonna try and do lone or Batman
you have to somehow isolate him from the
bat family and the ways the way they
decided to do that was just have them be
a jackass which
okay sure
it's kind of like Iron Man making
Hulkbuster he knew Hulk would go Rogue
well he didn't know but he knew that if
the Hulk ever did the risk was too great
to not have a contingency for that
Bruce Wayne is a walking pile of trauma
so it kind of makes sense yeah again not
making sense isn't the issue
favorite soup
um
probably
um clam chowder New England clam chowder
which is the only way that I will eat
clams or anything vaguely like clams but
again it's nostalgic I kind of grew up
on it
uh let's see
have I ever watched Blake 7 the actor
who played Travis in the first series
passed away I have not I did hear about
that though
because uh sort of a Sci-Fi group chat
thing that I'm in had people in it who
did watch bike seven so that came up so
I did know about that but no I haven't
uh I haven't seen Blake seven
um my name itself is not uncommon but my
spelling of it is
um it's even spelled wrong in our family
Association registry
uh what are the other animes that you
have watched and why didn't you like
them also since you're having so much
trouble thinking of series I'll ask what
are your top five anime movies Okay so
the other animes that I have seen
completely
were
um Helsing like the original Helsing not
Helsing ultimate and the first half of
Helsing is really good and then it goes
completely off the rails and it has a
climax that has nothing to do with what
had gone on up to that point it's a it's
a mess and then the other is Fullmetal
Alchemist which I know okay this one's
blasphemy but
I liked it enough to finish it so I
don't think it's bad but I don't love it
and like even some of the ones that I
would put on top three like Bebop I have
my reservations about I did an entire
video about some of my reservations
about that show but
um
with
uh Fullmetal Alchemist
you know I got to the end and I'm like
that was
fine
I don't ever need to watch it again
um and like Cowboy Bebop I did want to
watch again and I did do a re-watch but
yeah it just didn't it just didn't quite
work for me and I tried
I've heard people say that um Fullmetal
Alchemist Brotherhood is better
I tried to watch it but
it wasn't different enough to be
interesting
to me at least not early on and I was
not prepared to slog through however
many episodes it was going to be of
effectively the same thing
I'd already seen in order to get to the
new stuff
so that's um
that's that's where that's at
one of my controversial opinions is if
someone like Superman actually existed
they should be killed because uh because
them ever having something like a mental
break would be too much of a risk
I mean that's
that point of view is effectively what
they decide to have Batman feel in
Batman v Superman
I don't agree with that view however I
do think there are plenty of story
possibilities to be had by giving other
characters in the story that view and
sometimes that is part of rarely all but
sometimes that is part of Lex Luthor's
our motivation towards uh towards hating
um Superman and that tracks
um but if if we were to actually project
a Superman character into real life I
would not take that position
um but I would not disagree that having
the means to stop them would be a very
good idea
um starts humming the Helsing theme and
fan of myself I do have that to thank
for helsink is one of one of my most
performed burlesque numbers is to the
opening theme of the original Helsing a
song called A World Without logos I have
a hat and Kane number hat and came
burlesque number that is probably the
burlesque number I perform more than any
other
I love that number
and uh
I I will always be thankful for the
Helsing show even though I think it
falls apart really badly I will always
be thankful to it for um for introducing
me to that song
have you heard of Stein's gate it's an
anime focused on time travel that's a
unique take on the concept it's pretty
high concept basically they send texts
back in time I have heard of it I have
not watched it at this point
here's the thing I think back a decade
and most of the animes that I didn't get
around to just had to do with I had a
feeling I wasn't going to like them
enough these days there's enough things
that I hear about I'm like that does
sound interesting but like animes have
gotten longer
and gone on for more time and so now a
lot of them are massive time commitments
and I'm just like I no
I can't
what are your thoughts on found footage
movies like back rooms or creep I do not
enjoy found footage movies because
[Music]
they make me motion sick
I bailed on them fully after seeing or
trying to see Cloverfield in the theater
I had to rush out and throw up into a
trash can
and even and I did go back in after that
and ended up watching most of the movie
with my eyes closed and having to figure
out what was going on based on the
shouts of the characters
so uh my my thought on found footage
movies is
that
blah
do I like the song Highway to Hell by AC
DC I it's fine I actually don't know it
that well other than the chorus
um
not liking the first Full Metal
Alchemist isn't all that controversial
plenty of people don't like it that much
you said oh you never said top five
anime movies oh all right sorry about
that Alyssa uh so
ah top five anime movies
um
so
I'm going to place these in no
particular order
wow I can still tell you I can still
tell you which one uh is my number one
so my number one is Summer Wars
um others in no particular order would
include My Neighbor Totoro
um Ghost in the Shell
uh Princess Mononoke
and trying to round it out
thinking give me a second
um
probably
Millennium actress either that or
perfect blue
either one of those for the fifth spot
why do you think Batman has so many more
interesting villains than Superman I
feel like Batman has about 10 iconic
villains but Superman only has like two
well I think
part of it has to do with the fact that
since Superman has a much greater degree
of superpowers you you have to come up
with like the number of things that
could actually threaten Superman in one
way or the other it's much more limited
because Batman's just the guy you can go
Wilder with the gimmicks because
theoretically anybody with a gun could
stop Batman so they don't have to have a
certain minimum power level to be a
viable threat
because that's the thing with most of
Batman's villains they don't have
superpowers they have mental disorders
and a gimmick
but you can't threaten Superman with
nothing but that but you can be a threat
to Batman with nothing but that and it
just frees it up to go Wilder and go
more out there and when you have that
ability to just throw a lot more things
at the wall more of them are going to
stick
I think that's what it comes down to
I'm assuming you've never seen The Blair
Witch Project I've seen most of it I was
actually working at a movie theater when
it came out the year that it came out I
saw most of it not in order
ah
I'll be one year on estrogen a few days
oh Louise that's great
very happy for you
uh who's the hottest Doctor Who villain
and why is it Mr Finch
I do love Mr Finch but it might be Missy
it might be messy
that's another huge mistake the dceu
made no Batman Rose Gallery he
barely even met both of their Jokers
um
the dce had
there's going to be a there's going to
be a video on the current state of the
DC movies early into the new year
because James Gunn said uh there were
going to be announcements once we were
into the new year about what he was
actually planning because right now we
just know all the stuff that's been
canceled so I'm waiting on him saying
what they are planning to do
um that and then there will be a video
on that
ah
I really dig the world of cardboard
speech Superman gave in Justice League
Unlimited it's so good and oh I got
Justice League on league on the way to
complete areas for Christmas
which is especially good because HBO Max
is taking that show off the goddamn
stupid streaming service
but that speech is brilliant
I exist in a world of cardboard
I have to always hold back I have to be
careful
thank you
unless someone gets hurt
but you you can take it can't you big
guy oh it's so good that's so good nah
hottest Doctor Who companion oh
[Music]
um
Layla
she's in a leather bikini and she has a
knife it's Leela hahaha
Supreme Omega thank you once again for
the Super Chat on Superman it's ironic
that the TV adaptation like the 90s
Lewis and Clark and Smallville seem to
be more successful than the Cinematic
versions
well I think part of that was
especially at the time what they when
they started airing the expectations of
TV were also just lower and I don't mean
that as the disparagement that it sounds
like
um because I'm not going like well they
didn't have to be that good I meant like
they were they were given the leeway to
grow and explore things without being
like you better hit this minimum level
of fan pleasing the way that the movies
do
so like there's always a lot more
pressure put on the movies than the
shows for stuff like that
uh I think that view is only reasonable
if other super beings exist and uh
we need uh
then we need him to defend us again that
we need him to defend us against um
um I again I don't fully agree with that
but I don't really I don't really want
in this space today to get into a
philosophical argument on the merits of
murdering Superman
if he was if he existed in reality
um
yeah I don't really want to go too much
further down that road I'm not I'm not
in the head space and I'm I don't have
the spoons for that that
conversation today
um are there more big finish reviews
soon yes I plan to do another
um box set of Ninth Doctor
adventures in the near future
not making any promises as to when that
will be
but um yes that is planned
Ace in the tux from Ghost like yowza
like ghost lights want to need to
re-watch
how long ago did you watch Fullmetal
Alchemists if it was when it first came
out in 2003 do you think you would be
more willing to watch Brotherhood now
since it's been so long no I watched it
in 20
11.
I think I watched it
like I still have pretty decent memories
of it and I just like
yeah
even understanding that Brotherhood is
better like it it's still the same core
premise it's still the same core
characters which didn't enthrall me all
that much like it again I liked it
enough to finish it
but not enough to revisit it and I would
consider Brotherhood of revisitation
even if it is in some ways different
like maybe my opinion would be different
if I just watch Brotherhood first I
didn't
so and I don't think I'm not sure it was
out or at least it wasn't finished by
the time I watched the original Full
Metal Alchemist so like
I don't know what to tell you I I can
only I can I can only present you the
perspective that I have
did you watch neon jealous's Evangelion
nope uh only
mech suit style thing that I have ever
gotten all the way through was vision of
escaflone which I like a great deal
how far did you make it into American
Horror Story I love the first four
seasons but I'm struggling to get into
hotel hotel was the last one I watched
um
so that I've seen five seasons of
American Horror Story season one is fine
I like season two Asylum a lot I have a
lot of issues with coven did a whole
video on it I like uh season four I like
freak Show quite a bit Hotel just Hotel
had some good individual episodes
but it never pulled together all the way
and the characters were still great but
like it's story wise I was just starting
to feel like this is way too uneven
any actors I'd want for Knives Out Three
nope
um not off the top of my head
I I just want more
um so I'm actually thank you for the
reminder Carolyn
I'm gonna hop over uh to the Discord
real quick to tackle questions from
there from patreon supporters so I will
be back presently
let me see here
um where am I I'm in the wrong
thing here here we go
end of the year questions for the last
live stream what of the videos produced
this year was the most successful and
fulfilling to make ah two different
questions the most successful video was
the first one I did this year on Ezra
Miller
annoyingly the most fulfilling was a
video actually over on the Vera wild
Channel about
um only fans content creators I'm real
proud of that video
almost nobody watched it but that was
very fulfilling to finish and I'm really
proud of that one what's the best uh
favorite show movie scene or reviewed
this year unfortunately I can't answer
that one because that would effectively
serve as a spoiler for this Saturday's
video which is going to be my top 10 uh
things that I uh I took in this year
because that'll that'll include movies
video games and TV so can't answer that
one
what's the best Babylon 5 episode so far
that you've reviewed ooh
that okay
um hold on a second let me
I gotta I gotta pull up a list real
quick
so give me a second on that
let me get the episode list here we are
um
I liked by any means necessary a lot
um
huh
[Music]
um
honestly
that one might
still currently be my favorite
um or maybe
uh maybe and now for a word because I
thought for that style thing it was well
formatted
that there are a fair number of ones in
the conversation but those are the two
sort of Leaping to my head right now
so um let's see
back to the Discord
how do you feel about fictional stories
where a writer has some sort of Outsider
usually an alien or time traveler or
visit our Earth so they can use that
character express what they think is odd
or bad about Society
um
it's a fairly common conceit it can be
well done it is also one of those
conceits that can unfortunately lean
into
similar observations all the time or if
it leans too far into like kind of
turning into a cringe humor thing or if
it leans maybe a little bit too heavy on
like and hear all the ways that you are
bad but it can be done very well so like
just a quick example
um of it being done well actually from a
Babylon 5 episode I forget which episode
it was but there's one where Ivanova is
showing this um this very
supremacist-minded species that believes
themselves to be superior to pretty much
every other race around the station and
showing when Ivanova shows them the
basically the slum decks and how there
are people who you know they're down
there luck they end up here and these
aliens are like oh this is this is
wonderful you you have found a method
where those who are of lesser value to
society are shunted away and put here
this is excellent and it does a really
good job of
taking a species that we've already
learned is kind of horrible having them
praise Humanity for something that yeah
happens in like not just in the in the
fictional uh Society but like in our
society and they're being like this is
wonderful we love that you're like oh
crap so like you can definitely do it
well it is a concept that you have to be
careful how you go about it because
there's a lot of cliches and lazy ways
to do it but it's not an inherently bad
idea
uh when if ever is something being for
kids an excuse for World building that
doesn't make total sense
so recently Lily Simpson put out a 10
hour video pointing out absolutely
everything she disliked about the Harry
Potter Universe a lot of stuff she
pointed out I agree is bad because it's
problematic legal slavery anti-Semitism
Etc but I feel like some of the stuff
mentioned was kind of pedantic given the
books were created as escapism for
tweens like she said you'd have to have
English taught at Hogwarts for The
Wizarding World to have print media
which is true but I'm not sure it
matters yeah like that is pedantic and
honestly that's not even about it being
kids media I would think that's a
pedantic thing to point out for an adult
targeted piece of work to especially a
fantasy
like there's Magic
there's literal Magic
anyone who's gonna get that uppity
especially on a fantasy premise
no but like if I think where it gets
where you can like discard it with
things targeted kids is anything going
for a more fairy tale feel because when
you do fantasy there is for lack of a
better way to put it there's sort of
hard magic fantasy where things have
have clear rules then there's soft magic
fantasy which is your realm of fairy
tales where basically anything can
happen because
well it just can and if that's the kind
of story that you're telling you either
accept that that's the case or you
should just bail on the story because
it's not for you
and yeah there's plenty to dislike about
Harry Potter but stuff like that and
again like
for some people maybe that kind of thing
just gets stuck in their head and they
can't let it go I have stuff like that
too but that doesn't make it a an actual
deep flaw of the work that's kind of a
CinemaSins approach to criticism which I
don't find helpful
speaking of which something I was
wondering is what would you do if
someone paid you to review everything by
JK Rowling or just related to Harry
Potter and weren't able to get it
used don't worry not planning anything
just curious well okay I still
technically have my Harry Potter stuff
it is all packed away
um it's out of sight it's in a box in
the Attic
I haven't had the hard to actually eject
it from my house yet
I might one day or I might just leave it
up there
um
but the thing is like I've
I have reviewed
Harry Potter I did movie reviews for the
entire series through the second
Fantastic Beasts
and if somebody was like well do a
review of the books I'm like I you know
what
uh triple my normal fee for a book
that's what I would say uh in regards to
your specific question which seemed to
be about how would I acquire it uh
acquire those in a way that didn't
benefit her I still have them so that
part isn't an issue I would do I would
very much deliberately charge extra if
anybody try if anyone tried to give me
to review the movies I point out I
already did if they wanted me to review
the books triple the normal fee if they
wanted me to review the Fantastic Beasts
movie that I haven't seen yet uh five
times the fee
because that is that is a recent thing
and if they want me to review the video
game I would tell them no
flatly no
so there you go
uh favorite way to spend New Years also
happy holidays you know 2023 is awesome
for you and yours I don't know if I have
a favorite way because like I've done
I've done the gathering with people I've
done just you know my immediate family
in front of the TV I've done the big
party they're all nice and it's kind of
nice to like break it up from year to
year so it's not the same thing every
time so I don't I don't have a set
favorite way
ah do you think there is a way do you
think it's possible to create a heroic
main character
um
that's an XP of the doctor
I don't know what XP means but I guess
it means like equivalent
um space time travel included and it not
be called a doctor who ripoff
ah or is the character of the doctor too
much of an ingrained character for the
concept to work outside of the series
um
ah
you're gonna have to Tinker with the
nature of the heroism so
you know
when you
when you are doing something that is
similar to a very popular and very
well-known piece of work
you can have leeway in one of two areas
you can
do something very similar to the
character types and put them in new
settings
or you can use a similar premise but
with different character types if you
recreate both the premise and the
character type it's going to be called a
rip-off so you would have to make
alterations to the character whether it
be to make them gruffer and more sort of
jaded kind of like a rip Hunter style
character
um or you know and there's any number of
things that you could do but like if
if the character has a super similar
General Outlook in moral compass uh as
the doctor or most incarnations of the
doctors and sets inconsistent anyways
and also you're using the same
space-time travel core premise yeah no
you you need to shake it up because
recreating one or the other like you've
got leeway recreating both
with knives out and glass onions being
hits uh would you say we could see a
bigger Revival of the classic world's
greatest world's greatest detective
archetype I hope not here's why it is so
easy to do that really badly
like it
I love knives out and I love Glass Onion
and I love good detective stories I love
Colombo I love Poirot I love Nick
Charles
I don't need the world's greatest
detective archetype to become any more
popular than it currently is for the
very specific reason that I know what
happens when people who don't know how
to do it right try to do it which is
what always happens when when things
come out that are just imitating the
popular thing because the way that that
goes badly is you don't write a super
smart detective you just write everybody
else is an idiot so they are smart by
default because everyone else is stupid
and I hate that and because I don't want
to see that no I don't really want to
see the archetype become any more far
spread I'm really happy to see it back
with Benoit Blanc but I don't need more
uh now I've read the Nemesis sorry folks
there has been a a decent number of
these we're almost done now that I've
read the Nemesis series Dreadnought and
Sovereign I've read other original
superhero Pros novels so my question is
what would you say makes for better Pros
superhero costume something basic or
more elaborately described to mimic what
might be on a comic page or you or would
using a hero in the public domain be a
better option as a point of reference
ah
it's hard for me to say because
visual descriptions aren't my strong
suit with my own writing I don't think
I'm terrible at them but like I'm not
super great at them so I don't know what
would be the better way to do it
um and I don't think there's a default
because like
theoretically whether the costume is
more basic or more elaborate should be
more about what that says about the
character than whether it communicates
inherently Better or Worse on the page
so I actually don't think I can come at
that question from an angle where I'm
actually in a position to answer it well
if that makes sense
uh this is the first Christmas New Year
Without a new Who episode since the
start of the revive era do you miss it I
do but I also recognize that's why we
got the trailer on Christmas day so much
to my annoyance but
ah do you think RTD is trolling fans
nicely with BB the Meep and saying look
at the Flack you gave chibnol for the
patang versus the love I'll get for this
um
I think
I think he's trolling fans in so far as
let me take something that you assumed
could never be taken seriously and do it
anyways I don't think shibnol or the
pating are any part of his calculation
for selecting this
I on like I unless my opinion might
change when we start to see this stuff
but I do not expect that anything that
RTD is going to do is going to be
intended as a response to chimnal's era
at all I just don't think he's gonna do
that
uh and the spirit of the season is it
better to give or to receive
ideally both
simultaneously if you're limber
all right I am now back in the main chat
uh thank you for your patience folks
uh hello Jeffrey hello real life Jolie
good to see folks in here Colombo was
great because he never actually acted
like the world's greatest detective
usually kept his genius uh in a as a
secret to the person being investigated
that was part was great about him that's
also part of why I really like Nick
Charles because Nick Charles
everyone knows he's a great detective
but he's also a drunk and not like the
grizzle detective drunk he's a party
drunk he's a happy drunk he's a
functional alcoholic but people
underestimate him because they assume oh
his uh his days of you know being a
great detective are behind him like no
they're not
oh
uh how about a Murder She Wrote reboot
no
you can't recast Angela Lansbury no
got some more Super chats came in our
philosophy is thank you for the Super
Chat how long before they say Jody
was the last good doctor
um
uh I'd say
once we get to whatever doctor is after
shooting gotwa some people will then
start saying that
255 a D did you see the second part of
my first Discord question because it was
sort of important to why I asked I I I
did
um like I I did see it I just it it felt
like
um context that the folks in the chat
didn't need and my answer doesn't change
um based off not having said the second
half of that first question I did see it
I I factored into my answer
um
but it was context that I I didn't think
the chat needed so
I'm worried about coming out as by
gender to my dad not because I think
he'll be mad but I think he might not
care for good and Ill so might not
respect my pronouns and such
um
that is tough
and
unfortunately there's no magic phrase
that you can say that will ensure that
you are
understood and respected
depending on the nature of your
relationship with your father
hopefully
if he understands that it matters to you
even if it doesn't inherently matter to
him maybe he'll still try I don't know I
don't know him
but
if this is who you are and you
are at a point in your life where you
need the people who you care about to
know
it's probably still a good idea to tell
him
it's going to be
nerve-wracking
and if you are
very lucky
you will stress yourself out more than
ends up being warranted
you will
work yourself up be convinced that it's
um it's going to go badly have the
conversation and realize oh I got so
worked up over not all that much and
I hope
that's the outcome you get
excuse me I've got hiccups now
I was trying to say that I had an idea
of what to make you review next time I
actually have some extra money in my
pocket because of the poaro mention ooh
well I um intriguing real life Julie
Harry Dubois a beautiful exploration of
the detectives mentality I'm not
familiar with Harry Dubois I've heard
the name
drawing a blank though
um mum's side of the family is all
supportive moms struggled with the
pronouns but is trying
um and she has got good and not calling
me her daughter at least I mean and
that's the other thing even even the
people who want to are especially I
don't mean to like sound ageist about it
but especially older folks it's gonna
take more work because they're likely
not used to making the change and
they've also known you uh especially in
the case of parents your whole life so
that's a that's a lot of
a lot of time worth of ingrained habits
to
get to shift
the overlap between detective tropes and
autism tropes sure is a thing oh it is
I mean and it makes sense too a lot of
folks on the autism spectrum become
uh hyper aware of details uh so yeah no
it makes sense
if I were going to recommend you an
anime what kind of anime would you want
to be recommended oh I don't even know
like the thing is
trying to think of the easiest way to
put this
the reason I don't watch a ton of anime
shows is anime shows are far more likely
to engage in the kind of stuff that puts
me off anime than anime movies are
because
so regardless of genre
and regardless of anything else
any random anime that I pick there is a
there is about a 50 50 chance that I'm
gonna run into a bunch of tropes I can't
stand with excessive sexualization of
you know uh usually a young woman of
this whole like no nosebleed oh she's so
hot thing of the massive exaggerated
like the tear streams are all the way
there and the face is like
like I hate all that I hate it and I
know it's Trope and I know in some cases
um it it is done because that's like a
very clear way to bring a sense of
emotion across on a very low budget
because I understand a lot of these
things or at least the point at which
these things got ingrained as tropes
um were being done
uh to to save money and one like I
understand why they're there and I
understand part of it is cultural but I
hate that stuff and it shows up way way
more in the shows than it does in the
movies
and
yeah I mean to kind of pull from from
Yahtzee crochet you know he talked about
how he's selective with his options for
anime and he cites things like the
blatant fetishized fetitization of young
female characters of
um the trumps of like you can't have an
anime protagonist older than 25 if
they're 30 they're called the old man
um you know this huge massive focus on
the power of friendship Etc et cetera
and the way he put it was like and yes I
know not every anime does these things
but I think if I were to do a random
sample of animes it would just be a
matter of time before one or more of
these things would happen and that's I'm
kind of with him on that
uh sorry it's just I uh decided to
re-listen to the story after the
commission and I was like uh I get why
Banks wrote this in the Reagan area but
my go-to is it uh
but my uh my gosh is it preachy
um I mean I'll make that determination
when I get there like if you're gonna
pull something apart I'm not I'm
certainly not against pulling apart
Reagan Era
just World us especially
we are going to wrap up soon
just let you know I'm hanging out
a little longer than I might otherwise
because I the Discord questions took me
a little while
my brother was the first I came out to
which was great that's wonderful I was
struggling to accept myself as my gender
change and he told
I mean humans are soups of hormones
uh and it's all totes normal
that's great that's wonderful
I get that so much I'm very picky about
the anime that I like yeah and like
again I understand like the things that
make me go don't appear in every anime
but they appear in enough and I don't
I don't know how to look up does xanime
do do this Trope or not I don't know if
anybody's cataloging that
Death Note doesn't have that good to
know I have
death note I I hear is very good I have
not gotten to it
you know what would be cool uh a team of
world's greatest detectives that drive
around at a cool van cross country
solving crimes led by Velma detective
Jim Plastic Man Frylock uh Plastic Man
did you mean elongated man because he's
the actual detective Plastic Man plastic
man's just a loon
foreign
but anyways
I think we are going to wrap it up
pretty soon aside from the controversy
with the number 10 spot which of tots
were song picks were you most shocked by
I wasn't really shocked other than the
number 10. I wasn't really shocked by
any by any of them that said this is
easily the year where there were the
most songs that I'm like oh I kind of
like that song that were on his list
again I get why he doesn't like them but
I'm also like
yes I'm just a basic [ __ ]
uh story is the culture discovers Earth
and talk about how much it sucks
honestly I'm kind of in the mood lately
where I'm okay to be to be told
how much we suck because like somebody
else can list the reasons so I don't
have to come up with them because
there's uh
oh there's plenty
uh
uh oh well uh thank you everybody for uh
joining me I hope uh next time we do
this it'll be the new year so I hope you
have a good remainder of 2022
um so tomorrow
uh on Twitch
um at 10 30 a.m eastern time I will be
playing uh I think we settled on Lost
ruin I think didn't we Carolyn remind me
I think we settled on Lost ruin
um uh so
there's that um new take two Doctor Who
review will also be out tomorrow uh
Saturday is going to be my top 10 pieces
of entertainment of 2022. also Friday
I'll be streaming on Twitch again
um
and
think that about
does it for the immediate upcoming stuff
John vinyls sneaking in there with the
Super Chat thank you very much kippo is
really good by the way Scarlet Mane is a
lot like professor ratigan
he is a bit isn't he
slightly more uh unhinged but yeah a bit
oh that hadn't occurred to me
kippo was quite good that was a good
show
um but anyways thank you everybody for
tuning in I hope you have a wonderful
rest of the day wonderful rest of the
week a wonderful rest of 2022
cheers
and so what I really want you to
remember
is to be well
be safe be kind and remember that you
are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
mccavity